alors justement au prochain sommet
européen des 10 et 11 décembre les
discussions vont s'annonce tendu alors
que budapest associé à varsovie a mis
son veto au budget de l'union européenne
au plan de relance qui est adossé à ce
budget pour dénoncer un nouveau
mécanisme qui permettrait de priver de
ces fonds les pays qui ne respecteraient
pas l'état de droit est ce qu'on va
réussir à trouver un terrain d'entente
avec eux bah j'espère bien parce qu'il
faut une solution tout le monde attendre
l'argent donc donc il faut il faut un
succès là mais il joue surtout parce que
cette carte parce que ils ont peur ils
savent très bien qu'ils ne sont pas en
conformité le droit depuis longtemps
depuis dix ans en droit en hongrie
depuis cinq ans à pologne il
il ré ré désignent leur pays comme des
démocraties libérales comme et comme ils
disent
et maintenant il commence aussi essayer
de de redéfinir aussi les valeurs
européennes pas seulement leurs propres
valeurs mais aussi les valeurs
européennes et c'est tellement dangereux
il faut vraiment faire attention là
parce que si m si maintenant on en
étonnerait spa ferme des autres 25 pays
membres
on va changer leur l'union européenne ça
va pas rester la même union qu'avant
[Musique]